yeah
what's my safe word oh interesting
that'd be hilarious if one of us guessed
it
have we ever talked about safe words i
don't think we have i don't know if
you've ever told it to us it seems like
something i know you like to get your
ass beat and when you're having sex yeah
i don't know what your word is what is
it is it a single word or a phrase a
single word i can't wait to see this all
right ready one two three pineapple
pineapple
[ __ ] my safe word
is
[Music]
hi welcome back to another episode of
big mood thanks for hanging out with us
oh my god look who it is it's me it's
jess yeah you guys have been asking her
to be here and now she's here she had to
haul ass all the way from austin for
your dumb ass yeah i had to come all the
way to the city that i never want to see
again
i'm kidding i missed it
it's also me for listeners at home gina
hi
hi this is tiff
okay i'm really excited because we're
gonna play a game called the best friend
game who was made this was made by the
same people that made junk stone stupid
oh nice the game that we played so long
ago so shout out to dss games uh not
sponsored but i just made them send me a
bunch of games because i saw new ones i
was like i want all of them so they sent
it to me in a way sponsored just by
being kind of gifted friends yeah but we
like it and this is a game where
each of us get
each of us get a writing pad and a
pencil or a pen
and a marker yeah so a writing pad and a
marker and each person draws a card
racer too don't forget about the eraser
[Music]
each person draws a card
uh for instance my car can say
what's my favorite color and then these
two have to write down my favorite color
and on the count of three they show it
and this is a game of how well you know
you're better so it's like the hollywood
game it's like the newlywed game yes all
right
um there are so many cards here and
they're double-sided with different
questions so it's gonna this game is
there anything different between the
blue questions and the green questions
here i'll actually split these all right
so i'm gonna split these so i don't have
to keep passing stupid deck around so
here you go
okay
there you go wow look at that so this is
going to show you guys how close we
really are yeah all right
these are kind of sticky they're brand
new oh yeah it's like brand new brand
new or i just hear that crunch wait hold
on let's do some asmr
oh that's nice
[Music]
what do you think about this like and
send
let's go clockwise starting with tiff
okay so what any color
oh i definitely gotta do this one
already oh [ __ ] okay wait um you can't
wait do you want to choose oh yeah i
just dropped all blind it oh blind draw
it but i really want you to answer the
one that i just saw okay fine that can
be your first one but then blindfold
okay i'm blind drawing okay
when i was a kid what did i want to be
when i grew up
so we write the answer
we have to write a way to answer it but
do i write my answer no no no no no no
we're going to know
you're going to tell us okay okay yeah
you go ahead and write it first because
i want to know what you what if you
[ __ ] change your mind because that's
how the newlywed came yeah
yeah they write down that okay
okay what does she want to be when she
was a kid what did i want to be when i
grew up do you even know
i wanted to be a lot of things but i'm
gonna pick one i'm gonna write down a
lot of things
we don't know our friends at all um yeah
i don't know
oh i'm struggling on this one what did
steph want to be when she was a kid why
are you laughing right stupid ten
seconds ten i don't have an answer
right way down i don't know just the
right one you can't even think of a
thing right what your brain is blank
anything
go up
wake up
come on write something six
five
four
three
two i don't know what to call it one all
right ready i'm gonna count up a word
you guys go first i'll show you mine all
right i wrote
a singer
that's not a terrible idea yeah i made
up a word okay it's a word that's in
spanish but i don't think it exists
what i wrote
what is that that's not a word
i just said i made up a word
like when you're a kid i can imagine you
wanting to sell [ __ ] popsicles
no i'm laughing because this is
literally everyone's childhood dream at
one point who grew up in the 90s like
early 2000s okay famous
marine biologist oh why didn't we all
want to dude
why did we all have a phase that wanted
what do you think is that they just
collect samples out of dirty water all
day i don't know why did we want to do
that
to giant animals like sea animals
okay jess your turn
i picked this one okay on purpose just
because i want you guys to roast me okay
what's something i do that annoys you
but i have to guess yeah you have to
guess okay
i hate this game
it's making me realize i use autocorrect
way too much
over here misspelling [ __ ] i just made
up a word so it's fine okay that's true
wait i'm not done uh uh
wait you said roast but i don't know i
feel like this is real
no that's that's what i remind you i
mean
roasting really that's what i wanted
because i feel like we always say nice
things about each other but you can go
ahead that's true talk [ __ ] to me that's
if you go first okay i wrote you scared
instantly rejects ideas slash activities
true i've already made up my mind about
a lot of [ __ ] yeah and it's like an
instant no from jess it's like don't
even bother
i'm like you can't just you can convince
me though that's the thing is like you
gotta
no wait hard no is it's like there's no
room for there's no way do you remember
one uh think of one let's hear what gina
says i wanna everyone remember one
because i wanna see if i feel like you
could have convinced me or not actually
i could think of one okay okay uh when
we wanted to do a tick-tock for big mood
girls oh yeah and you're like instant no
no i said i just didn't want to do it
exactly you're part of this
participation [ __ ]
no and like i'll be in the background
but i don't want to run it no that's
what i'm talking about all right my
answer is
make me realize how dumb i am but thank
you for that
i i need it
a lot of times it's annoying it's not
it's not that's funny well i mean it's
not annoying
but it's like [ __ ] how dare you make me
reflect upon myself you have nice what
do i do
like whenever i call you crying about
something you're like
no one [ __ ] cares about it it's not
that big of a deal you're fine or like
gina this is your fault you know that
right it's like [ __ ] you're right that's
not annoying is it annoying to me is it
annoying it's not annoying it's like
endearing you said thank you so it's not
annoying yeah
i want a better one you love fun
she's nowhere nice
i know hold on you're gonna [ __ ]
roast me okay fine so go over here like
telling me that i make you better
when you were a picky eater way back
when when i first started yeah yeah that
was really annoying it was rough to like
rip the white out of me yeah yeah i know
it was she came to l.a and she became
cultured with food yes we're good yeah
and now i'm like
i'm back in austin and i'm like there's
no god damn hong kong chinese food
around here
she's changed she's cultured she's going
she's the same but but the uh opposite
yeah a little bit more yeah
all right what do you think yeah i just
want to talk too much [ __ ] i just feel
like i'm annoying annoying like i can i
know like directly to you though like i
talk too much to you no right i feel
like that's annoying that's fun i feel
like i annoy people
yeah i guess it depends what you're
saying it depends on who though it's
gotta do with my mouth one way or the
other it depends on who and how people
take it
yeah
all right i don't think it's that bad
okay my turn
who would i call if i had to get rid of
a dead body
between the three of us i mean in
general i think and like generally in
life yeah
i know who yeah i know get rid of a dead
body
i don't know if you'll get mad if i
write this
i wonder who it is i'm like i don't know
if you're gonna cause my answer if you
guys got it right if it's the right
answer i wouldn't get mad at that okay
well we'll see well the i know who i'm
calling
basically who would i call i know but
i'm like i think maybe you might
as well i don't know okay so me who
your dad
who
i put bart or joe hell no my dad there
he goes
why would you want to put your dad at
one point because i feel like he's
experienced i know that he would right
but we don't want
we don't want your dad to go to jail i
call him because i'm confident that he
will probably not go to jail for this
because he's he's more he's learned like
he's older he's probably the best person
to call yeah so i
i guess
mad was the wrong word more like you'd
want me to not have that be my answer
for some reason oh no because you're
really protective of your dad yeah yeah
yeah that's fine no he would he'd be
down and then you can circle like the
thing here for one point oh yeah i get
one point yeah the first person okay so
i put them because
number one if they get caught it's okay
for them to go to jail yeah right number
two
they would like actually probably
they would be down they'd be down i feel
like they'd be down yeah yeah i feel
like and also you wouldn't be getting
your dad in trouble that is true wait
but who said you you have to get in
trouble that is true
that's a part of like helping bury your
body is the fact that you could get
possibility i feel like my dad would be
the only person in the world that
wouldn't snitch on me too
and my sister okay i wouldn't snitch on
you yeah
well no what if they came to be like if
you don't tell us we take your son what
that's not a thing you know what if they
what if it's like the fbi yeah
if they're that if they're like that if
they got that much evidence yeah
no all right or like if it was like the
what if i kidnapped someone or have to
bear the body and their family finds out
and they come to you like
like it's not authorities it's family
members or friends or a gang member or
something like we're gonna take your kid
if you don't tell us who did it oh so
you feel like your dad would take all of
the like fingernails ripping out like
yeah torture my dad would not switch me
out for sure okay yeah
like if they were gonna torture me
if they're gonna physically torture me
or someone around me i guess i would
write you out but borrowing the torture
yeah
a normal situation i would hold it
forever
i would hold my tongue
you know we keep secrets [ __ ] well you
guys do you know we keep secrets yeah
you guys do for the worst yeah exactly
yeah jesus all right all right ready um
would my parents say i was a
well-behaved child
okay
ready one two three no no lupita
that was supposed to be my name because
i was born on december 12th oh my god i
forgot about yeah that was my mom's due
date oh thank god you didn't have that
imagine having to introduce that in our
podcast hey guys meet gina and lupita
you know like
you know lupe guadalupe the whole name
yeah i mean it's one name
what about
oh do i get a point too no no no that's
your old point yeah
you know what's funny actually
okay never mind it's kind of sad okay
you're gonna regret that one later okay
no fine i'll say it what i was gonna say
is my parents wouldn't know oh
well your mom put you on medication to
make you
shut up so i'm like she probably thought
you weren't well behaved yeah
your turn blindly
blindly picking describe my style in one
word
like fashion style but make it funny
yeah fashion style wrong answers only
[Laughter]
describe my style in one word well what
you're wearing now is easy
like normal you have other stuff that's
like okay jess
[Music]
okay one two three casual grandma
don't know how we're gonna score this
but i wrote basic basic
that's funny casual basic
the reason why i wrote grandma though is
because you know you get into your
grandma moods when you're like i don't
want to show an ounce
of skin that's called modernity my dude
i feel like grandma's more like doilies
and like yeah like a like lace yeah
yeah i say you're casual you're my
grandma in like the fabrics yeah but i'm
more like covered up from head to toe
right that's what i meant by grandma
yeah okay i got basic i feel like basic
cat cat really casually
kind of goes yeah give yourself a point
gina yeah okay yeah i'm wrong but i
think the wrong word okay you know what
i wrote at first
what
[Music]
did you
like okay i was actually gonna write
white casual right
you said it was one word only oh my god
fine i'll go with you
i thought
basic white
[ __ ]
but i was like it's too many words but
like when i think of basic white girl i
think of like the infinity scarf yeah
like the boots the brown boots were like
in the fall
yeah you're talking about like starbucks
yeah michaela is my kid's name
actually a lot of what i'm wearing now
is like work clothes and so i look more
like i think they call it smart casual
so it's like
nicer
stuff yeah but like still with jeans but
i'll wear like loafers and like a nice
top and stuff but like whatever work
[ __ ] uh smart casual smart casual
casual smart casual white casual
yeah i know i don't buy a lot of clothes
oh okay let's see
all right my card is
what's my favorite make of car
it's my favorite car
so does it have to be specific yes well
no not the model but what what's my
favorite maker or the the you've said
this before mm-hmm i just don't remember
i'm gonna guess but i don't know
okay
on count of three go
honda some japanese name you're putting
some rice rocket nissan my favorite car
is a lamborghini
what let me see a lamborghini
said that this sense
my dream car is a lamborghini countach
or diablo what's a diablo i think you're
talking about old vintage ones i thought
you were talking about something more
realistic
it could be realistic
you will never spend money on that if i
had the right amount of money how much
money would you yeah
oh millions millions millions and
especially like maintenance like every
maintenance like 10 grand
yeah but knowing you and how you spend
your money you don't see your money ever
spending money on a lambo i it depends
on how much money like if it's like a
drop in the bucket kind of thing well
it's you know it's like like you're
willing to spend one percent yeah we'll
see of you'll still be living here yeah
i'll still be living right here not
going anywhere you're the only person in
my life that i've ever met that has zero
lifestyle creep like makes more money
the lifestyle creep doesn't happen yeah
it's like where you you kind of start
living like according to your means as
you get higher and higher you've stayed
the same broke [ __ ] lifestyle
shitty card shitty like house with a
bunch of roommates and it all came like
paying like a hundred dollars for rent
yeah i like the amount of money in your
bank account yeah
like pisses me off
i use them you have such like
you have so much um what is it like
net worth
that and just like self-control when it
comes to money yeah [ __ ] dude like i
want to have fun with my money i can't
imagine like just saving all of it it's
because you're bursting all of it the
first time i made money i blew it all on
traveling
like you should have had something left
yeah which like i don't regret but now
it's like now that i'm you're extreme on
one end and then on the other hand yeah
you went
really far the other way
i want to die that old lady with like a
bunch of money in her mattress please
put me in your will are you feeling a
little anxious and overwhelmed these
feelings can make it hard to shift gears
and get in the mood with dipsy you can
focus just on what makes you feel good
dipsy is an app full of hundreds of
short sexy audio stories designed by
women for women they bring scenarios to
life with immersive soundscapes and
characters no matter who you're into or
what turns you on find stories about the
intriguing co-worker with a british
accent or hooking up with your hot yoga
teacher hear the sexy voices of saronis
j jackson er fightmaster luke cook and
many other stories like you've never
heard before new content is released
every week so in between listening to
your favorite stories again and again
you can always find something new to
explore dipsy also has sleep stories
wellness sessions and now they also
offer written stories it's your go-to
place to spice up your me time explore
your fantasies or heat things up with a
partner for listeners of the show dipsy
is offering an extended 30-day free
trial when you go to dipsystories.com
mood that's 30 days of full access for
free when you go to
d-i-p-s-e-a stories dot com slash mood
once again that's tipsy stories dot com
slash mood does my car have a name if so
what is it what
ah god damn it i don't know does your
car have a does
answer that
does my car even have a name
and if so what is it yeah one
two three no name
no no name
no i was gonna write down rosie for some
reason rosie i've
yeah
it does have a name you guys what is it
it's tickle
oh i've seen that for tiff kate wait
tiff
tiff isaac casey oh yeah luca yeah
yeah so my our wi-fi is called tickle
manor
oh that's actually cute guys
i didn't know that you didn't i thought
that was a pretty good idea but i never
heard you say like oh you know let's hop
everybody's getting in the tickle tickle
tickle mobile yeah that sounds like a
fetish kidnapped man
get in the tickle mobile kids yeah
no but you know when i first got the
tesla um isaac would call all the teslas
that he would see on the road like tick
fams or t-fams oh
he's like hey mom there's another t-fam
how cute so that's where it kind of got
gave me the idea because you can name
your tesla yeah they give you an option
oh so i have it mine just says jessica
it's like it's just like hello jessica i
should i should put something like hello
broke [ __ ] or something like that
everybody getting the tickle mobile
tickle come here kids getting tickle
mobile oh god it's creepy
okay i need to pick one now if i could
switch places with a president
a celebrity or a famous athlete for a
year what do you think i would choose
hmm
president celebrity or famous athlete um
and i'm gonna be specific
of the person but you don't have to be
specific okay no oh i think because i
don't even know if this is the right
answer
but this is just who i want to trade
places with okay ready
one two three president
oh
okay
i would say i think gina is gonna win on
this one because what i wrote down is
tom hardy's wife
yeah i feel like that's a celebrity nice
not an athlete yeah yeah yeah i could
see the president thing but also that's
way too much [ __ ] stress way too many
people's [ __ ] opinions yeah that's
what i was thinking but the other two
are so okay the reason why i picked
president is because yes they're a very
well-known person
but they can make decisions and you're a
very decisive person you like your
opinions and you're you stick to them
and you you'll get it done yeah i didn't
pick celebrity or athlete because
both of them are just too like in the
public like you don't want to be in the
public so much even the president
obviously is but
like what the [ __ ] do you gain out of
that
nothing and you probably wouldn't want
to be athlete
athlete at first because it's like
you're pretty fit you work out and i
feel like that's less
demanding than being a celebrity with
like paparazzi all over you yeah so i
wrote athlete first i didn't say
president because i don't think you want
that amount of responsibility over so
many stupid people
um so i wrote celebrity because it also
gives you the option of just
being a celebrity for like no reason
just being rich and buying whatever you
want enjoying it
yeah yeah but does your answer
technically count as a celebrity yeah
his wife is a celebrity too right but
you don't know her name because i always
need to know is tom hardy's name she is
not important
it's like
like uh oh my god what's up amal
cooney's husband i mean yeah yeah yeah
cooney's husband right
wait is that her name george clooney no
yeah what's her last name not cooney
clooney clooney i said cooney yeah
um yeah no i think i definitely would
not choose any of them so i was curious
to see what you guys
would lean towards oh give yourself a
point oh i think that one kind of works
because that was the closest one yeah
because athlete i'm just not that
interested in sports
and then president like i think that
would just be way like being a celebrity
on our z level
is already so hard yeah that like being
at the number one known person in the
world is no [ __ ] way
so i would have to just stick with
celebrity being a president sounds
[ __ ] miserable
yeah that's gotta be the worst job not
about it but you can make a lot of like
moves that benefit you and your family
yeah that's true
that's true that's what they all do
every single year pretty much it's true
every single family that hits that
office is just doing [ __ ] for themselves
mostly all right mine is
what city was i born in
oh
you have mentioned this before and
raised
you're trying to [ __ ] figure it out
because i'm like i know where you were
raised
keep in mind though i was raising two
different i know yeah oh jesus that's
why i only know one of them i think okay
ready [ __ ] yeah ready all right one two
three i cheated san jose
would you put a alhambra or san jose i
was born in san jose okay yeah yes so
secondly you yeah yeah
i put two i know
that's like me putting tijuana and i was
never racist
i was ever raised in alhambra
yeah well you went to high school
i knew it was san jose yeah you second
guessed yourself no i totally did
oh my turn
would i rather have no hands or no
genitals
[Music]
damn i don't know which one i would want
[ __ ] so no hands or no genitals what do
you think ready one two three
genitals
yeah genitals
no genitals in no [ __ ] world do i
imagine you getting rid of your hands
yeah just for sex yeah yeah no thank you
i mean genitals are good for other
things too like having kids doing birth
yeah that but also like you know peeing
and
things you don't have to hang out
genitals necessarily you could just have
a hold of pee and put it it's a bag it's
[ __ ] colostomy
yeah
yeah yeah i don't know hands are far
more useful for sure that's on a daily
basis i was thinking like because how
are you going to hold your stupid baby
you know
yeah you definitely i mean nubs
yeah i guess no you wouldn't choose that
you're too much with my genitals
you're too much of a mom
you need your hands yeah i need my hands
i just thought it was a funny question
this might be funny though what do i
absolutely hate
wait i just i noticed i just gave myself
a point when you guys got it right
i only have two points i think what do
you absolutely hate what do i absolutely
hate
i think it's shorter to write what you
don't hate
it's true
absolutely would be like the next
absolutely like for sure okay
okay
ready
one two three go men
i put mess
a mess we're both matter of faces too i
was about to put men but i'm like she's
not gonna put me i don't think it's like
the number one name but i feel like
that's something that you hate a lot i
don't know what the number one she
doesn't hate a lot she doesn't hate a
lot but she's like she is very
annoyed
dislike not hate dislike what is the
best answer i can come up with i would
say would you actually say you hate me i
don't think you no i don't think so
because my dad is like my favorite
person
and i have a brother okay about soylent
okay yeah so it's mainly [ __ ] just
shitty like i'm willing to be extremely
vocal about shitty men mm-hmm yeah but i
don't hate almond mm-hmm right
that's great so would you write i wrote
liars liars okay
i absolutely hate life number one and
i'm not talking about little white lies
and we run into those there's little
stuff that happens but okay
second
number
one
fall in that category
this is the this is the umbrella
i would probably write liars too because
you guys remember that story i told
about the guy who like wouldn't come
clean about that phone
just like little [ __ ] like that where
i'm like
you're it's just you can't be
trustworthy yeah a white lie where it's
like oh that shirt's cute like that's
fine but like
lying to me about [ __ ] that matters
that pisses me off okay yeah
i don't know how you guys are gonna
[ __ ] know this one but thanks for
picking all the hard ones
all the others
um
actually you guys might know if you paid
attention to my social media enough but
i know i'm never on
[ __ ] how many speeding tickets have i
received oh [ __ ] like ever mm-hmm well i
would assume there's a difference
between the number of times you've been
pulled over and the number of tickets
you've got yeah tickets in general or
specifically okay all right ready one
two three go
okay
uh two
two it was back to back in a span of 24
hours oh my god really speeding tickets
in a row [ __ ] seattle pd wow
i was heading to a um a race competition
and you're waiting
weren't you oh my rental was a mustang
it was my birthday too
so when was this this was 2000. on her
birthday 18 to 14 or 15. um i wait for
the only tickets you've ever gotten your
whole life yeah oh [ __ ] shout out to my
lawyer for getting it off thank you
um but it was a little mustang was it uh
i don't remember
but it was i went to the car rental
place i'm like oh it's your birthday
we'll give you an upgrade i'm like give
me a mustang yeah and then the cops were
waiting like outside of the like um a
few miles away from the
race so they knew people were coming in
yeah all the cars and so they were just
having a [ __ ] field day pulling
people over and i was only going like
five over wow but they were being
dictated to everyone yeah just pulling
it's got a reason to get a ticket right
that's crazy i thought you were called
mustang white oh okay yeah like a red
one or something yeah i
i was heading in
five miles over whatever 24 hours later
in the same morning i go back five miles
over the same thing i was like you gotta
be [ __ ] kidding yeah that was
definitely a racket cause like when i
was driving from california to austin i
got caught going 97 in a
70
and they didn't give me a ticket one
yeah so nice
you they decide when they want to give
you a ticket yeah they were just pulling
people by the tree i think they were
just like [ __ ] these race people yeah
like [ __ ] them all you're targeted [ __ ]
them to hell yeah they made their quota
in one day yeah that's ridiculous
that's why you get good lawyers okay
so you got out of it yeah okay five over
dumb yeah yeah that's that's like that's
too close i feel like they shouldn't
give you a ticket for anything less than
ten because i feel like even sometimes
like just there's too many things that
could happen i've gotten two tickets
that i can remember i'm pretty sure it
was just two but both of those they were
in a particular it was going to san
diego and there's this one part of that
stretch from l.a to san diego where it
all it goes downhill mm-hmm and they
were [ __ ] camping oh my god they were
camping out right there pulling people
over for the downhill speed and i got a
ticket they're twice annoying but like
years apart i would fight that's so
annoying i didn't i had a downhill i'm
like whatever it adds points to your
insurance though i know but yeah i'm
just i'd rather get hit and pay the
money than deal with everything else so
i'm like i'll just buy this expensive
i know it was
it was stupid and i have to it stays
with you it stays with you for a long
time like four years some more seven i
don't know i don't forget
okay my turn
on a scale from one to five how strict
were my parents when i was growing up
five being the strictest
okay
ready one two three one five one five
one being the three
somewhere right in the middle oh yeah so
that was your party stories and stuff
like that like damn your parents that
you got partying [ __ ] no [ __ ] i snuck
out wow i picture your mom being like
you i cannot [ __ ] believe you left
this house yeah no she literally caught
me once
sneaking out from my bedroom window
because i would leave the window open
because i'm like okay i just want to
make noises one time and i would move to
my stepdad snores nice like
he was swearing
yeah
because we had wood floors and it was a
raised bed yeah ray's foundation snoring
[ __ ] yeah that [ __ ] was loud and so
every move i made was to his snores so
i'd be opening the window like
oh my god that is so funny and i think
my mom's like intuition tingled or
something because one because i had i
was doing this a lot i was sneaking out
a lot because she would only let me go
out
i had to pick
one day to go out for the weekend so i
couldn't go out like friday and saturday
or thursday and friday whatever i had to
pick right
and my my curfew was at midnight so
which is so nice that's high school yeah
that's so loud i know it was pretty no
wait was it midnight no it was 11. it
was 11 o'clock but still that's [ __ ]
late yeah for a 16 year old that's super
late um so
i would go out to parties i would pick
my one day
and usually on fridays and then on
saturdays oh well first of all i'd come
home at 11 on my curfew i'd say good
night pretend to go to sleep and have my
friends wait around the corner and i'd
sneak out of my window and go party
until before the sun came out because i
still wanted to be dark before like when
i would come home so that's that was my
thing every weekend friday and saturday
sometimes even sundays i would sneak out
of my window and go party but this one
day she caught me
she when i came back through the window
she was sleeping on my bed so i fell
asleep on the floor by the window and i
just left the window open i'm like i'm
not gonna wake her up and i woke up to
her beating my ass oh my god
and
i deserved it
you should have been like mom you were
sleepwalking and you kicked me out of
bed i've been here the whole entire time
you're crazy
yeah no but i mean she tried she tried
to give me rules and i just didn't care
yeah that's why i put like a three she
wasn't super like yeah do whatever you
want but she also wasn't like the
strictest yeah i guess so yeah yeah i
would have been five i wasn't allowed to
even sit my front door what yeah they
were crazy damn crazy
yeah
what's my favorite website
wrong answers only what the [ __ ]
favorite website oh god damn it this
[ __ ] here we go i got one
stupid
the [ __ ] has a favorite website which is
early internet neopets is my favorite
website the [ __ ]
i picked this because i knew you were
going to react that way
did you write your answer
only she even knows her answer i'm
coming up with my answer right now
what website do i go to like every day
i know you don't go to this every day
but i think it's funny all right you
definitely don't it was too short
one two three bmw.com
psychology today.com oh
so now this [ __ ] is like you study your
cars and you look up your car i bought
an audi yeah
i got that one yeah
i wrote psychologytoday.com because
you're always looking at i do studies
and i do that yeah i do do that a lot or
or second one would be like webmd to see
if you're dying or not
that is very true yeah i'm always
looking up symptoms
[ __ ]
but on every day basis surprisingly wait
let me kiss it again let me guess again
no not bunch houses hypochondriac yeah
yeah yeah yeah it has a different name
now too i forgot oh really yeah they've
kind of changed it and i know that
because
um
apple news
that's a big one apple news for sure it
definitely reads that's my second game
okay that's my second guess what is it
i don't post anything yeah but i like
every day when i'm bored i scroll
between probably apple news and reddit
oh yeah there's also like an austin one
that i'm like i paid attention to a lot
yeah and then like dating over 30
and then like there's a wait no read it
so i'm on there a lot and then there's
like there's also one called regretful
parents oh yeah i lurk in there a lot
it's about people who had who are on the
fence had kids and are now [ __ ] hate
their kids because i feel like it's the
most honest place and right the [ __ ]
internet i'm gonna [ __ ] read that
shin because i ever feel like i want to
have a kid
well i want to shut down i want to read
it just so i can feel dreadful just
kidding
yeah like it's
regretful parents regretful parents i
think parents yeah that one's pretty
crazy okay jeez interesting and then
like there's yeah there's just a bunch
of cool ones like i didn't really i
always kind of avoided it for the
longest time and then i got on there one
time for some other reasons and then i
just started going all around read it
and fell in love with it but yes i have
not posted i like read it too i like um
i like following shrink-flation what's
that so it's when they show products
that used to be one thing but then now
with the inflate like they're shrinking
their products to still charge you the
same product but less productive that's
what you're into i like it i find it
interesting because i'm like yeah
starbucks [ __ ] did that with my bacon
gouda sandwich
significantly smaller no i'm talking
about it
i could see that on
the subreddit mildly infuriated that's
the other one
no so yesterday or two days ago whatever
it was
is there a hole in it
there's a whole ready for that it looks
strange i wanted to post this other one
but i didn't because i don't post on
reddit either but i wanted to post so i
recently had minute maid
uh bottled orange juice and i remember
back in the day those bottles used to be
so it's kind of like a body shape yeah
they changed the shape yeah now the
[ __ ] the the cinched part is like way
more cinched so it's really skinny yeah
and i tasted the orange juice and i
remember mine made back in the day would
be like so delicious like it tastes like
actual freshly squeezed juice now it
tastes like watered down concentrate
disgusting orange juice you know what
orange juice is really good and i'm
sorry you can't get it here but at heb
all my texas friends will know the
[ __ ] fresh squeezed juice from h-e-b
it's not pasteurized or anything like
they literally just take oranges
and squeeze it and bottle it yummy and
you can only drink it within like a day
or two all right this is pretty
interesting yeah right it is pretty damn
good
like one day thing to read
the texas toast the texas toast is like
it's like regular toast now yeah
there's a skinny bottle yes
even simply lemonade made them skinnier
that's so [ __ ] and they charge the
same order slightly more so you know
this whole inflation thing too is a scam
because like companies have record
profits right now so they're they're
they're using inflation as an excuse to
charge us more but they're actually
going way above
and they're having record [ __ ] prices
this is robbery more than at any other
time where is our uh robin hood because
this is [ __ ] the taxi it's crazy
it's crazy
all right
what was my first job
oh
oh i gotta go on the roller deck first
look you had a bunch of i know my very
first one like as a kid or like as an
adult as a i guess an adult yeah more of
an adult
like legal first job you know
i can i can legally i can work
i'm just going to put an answer
yeah i got my answer
ready one two three
import model go go dance
you know i had a job before these right
no you were always just a model yeah
you're always just hot you're you're
you're your job is to be hot no
since inception oh i literally was just
talking about you or about this with you
earlier too my first job was front desk
at a hotel oh i don't know why don't you
tell me that earlier when i told you i
worked front desk at a hotel at a
chinese ass best western and they served
tea eggs and congee for breakfast
i don't remember you telling me you
worked there yeah that was totally just
all i heard was the kanji and i was like
and i like didn't hear the rest of the
symptoms
i was front desk at the best western
it was in a super chinese area it was
the worst job ever because i had morning
shift which is torture i used to be a
front desk person at a hotel really he
knows that hotels they own the hotel and
they [ __ ] suck damn
in high school i don't because i have
that job oh yeah in high school i did a
internship thing like the a program
where you could pick where you want to
work
like through school yeah and i worked at
a hotel yeah but i was in a front desk
girl mm-hmm i was a hostess it was the
worst decision at the restaurant oh
yeah that was my first job i hated it i
lost maybe like two months when i'm out
of here dude and like the the uh the
manager because it's a franchise or
whatever the manager
was like one of those people who has
terrible breath and every time he talks
he has to get this close
and you back up he's got this close no
and they ran it super like shitty too
it's like all right the best westerns
are usually do you remember what was
your pay for your first job oh i don't
remember
i remember want to say like six or seven
dollars i can't remember mine was 5.75
an hour yeah that could be right i don't
remember it was so it was at hometown
buffet oh nice i was a hostess there oh
yeah i do remember that job that was
your first job that was my first job in
the united states
excuse me
she was a responding person before no
no what are they called what's the name
yeah the cell what's the how do you what
is their job uh like if you were to
refer to them as palette no that that's
ice cream
elotero is for the elotes
[Music]
that's just the thing though right yeah
it's a thing so there's not a name for
the people who sell it they're they're
probably there is but i just don't know
that's why i came up with that word
because yeah
no so
my first job here in the us i got when i
was 16.
but my whole 15th year i lived in mexico
and when i was in mexico i had multiple
jobs i worked at a
internet cafe
i worked at my uncle's um
restaurant where i had multiple
positions where i was the cashier i was
a waitress
i was the food prep girl
um yeah so what was your first first
first ever was i think it was the
internet cafe okay
that's true yeah okay yeah yeah what's
your first job
the first job that i can remember i was
like a camp counselor for like a summer
camp thing that was held in town though
it was like so i grew up in port aransas
and there's like like a the city pool
and then so there would be like this
camp that they would like a day camp
that like the kids would come and we
would teach them how to swim and like do
different activities and stuff and so
like i was one of the counselors at that
that i think that was my first
job but like i did babysitting and stuff
like that before too like cash you know
just cash jobs and stuff like that but i
think an actual where i actually got a
check yeah it was the camp counselor
thing yeah that's why i don't really
count the mexico ones
because that was like paid with cash and
it wasn't hourly it was like a
the internet cafe one i think it was
like
per day
and then at my uncle's is per week
but i i think i got like 25 for a whole
week at my uncle's restaurant or
something crazy like that i don't know
it was a lot of money back then
for 15. 2005 15 years old in 2005. to me
when i was 15.
25 bucks for a whole week oh a week yeah
a whole week girl yeah
at least a day's worth child labor bro
should probably go home and sue yeah
because i'm like that was like nothing
today's episode is sponsored by honey
the easy way to save when shopping on
your iphone or computer oh my gosh did
you know that you could do it on your
iphone too i didn't know until recently
but anyway i've been using honey forever
i love honey i use it all the time i
don't think there's a time i've gone
online shopping in the past like six or
seven years that i haven't used honey
like imagine you're shopping for clothes
like my cousin has a wedding next week
and i needed a dress i just did this um
i was shopping for a dress i put found
the dress put it in my cart i go to
check out and honey immediately starts
searching the internet for promo codes
it searches for all of the possible
promo codes you could possibly use and
it finds you the very best one like the
one that saves you the most amount of
money and then it applies that directly
to your cart and you don't have to do
anything you don't have to search google
you don't have to
sign up for an email list to get spam so
that you could get promo codes no none
of that honey does it all for you and
honey is free it's a free shopping tool
i use it for literally anything i'm
shopping for online and it doesn't just
work on desktop it works on your iphone
too like i mentioned you just activate
it on safari on your phone and you save
on the go there you go so if you're
online shopping at the last minute or
maybe your dress gets hung up at the
baggage claim or something i don't know
uh maybe i'll have to order another one
and i'll use honey on my phone it's so
easy if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting the show i never
recommend something i don't use i use
this all the time get honey for free
f-r-e-e at joinhoney.com
mood that's join honey.com
mood m-o-o-d
what's my dad's name first name what's
my dad's first name [ __ ] i don't know
am i supposed to just make up a name i'm
going to make up a spanish i said his
name he has a dope name
i like his name what okay well that's
not what i was thinking of then [ __ ]
what were you gonna say juan roberto
okay yeah no his name is i like his name
a lot we almost named
luca his after your dad after my dad uh
for his middle name does he have an
uncommon name i don't know because to me
it's it's known because it's my dad's
name yeah i don't know okay i have
literally zero idea just think of a
of a masculine mexican name oh i find it
very much hold on hold on
this is the first thing that pops into
mine i'm probably wrong but whatever
okay ready
i'm just making a name
okay all right let's go ready one two
three antonio gabriel
oh okay
it's actually gustavo
gustavo
that is way manlier that's right
i love his name gustavo yeah could be
italian too no so recently uh we went to
we were in new england for casey's
brother's wedding and we stopped by at
salem massachusetts which is yeah so we
were looking at a whole bunch of like
witch stuff and all that and in front of
the bookstore like in the window there
was this really cute like pretty big
book that's called gustavo the ghost
and it was all in pink and it had like
papel picado everywhere it's like a
mexican uh you know the paper that's
like cut out that it's like a banner oh
okay stuff that like hangs on yeah
that's a festival so it was like all
decorated with that and it was so pretty
and then i was like oh my god
let's buy this for luca as like a salem
souvenir slash also reminds me of my dad
because his name is gustavo and also we
don't know if he's a ghost or not
so
okay well that was cute until the end
yeah
so like well think of my dad every time
we read this so you bought it yeah i
bought it i want to see it yeah it's so
cute i'll send you guys a picture yeah
all right let's trade stocks real quick
yeah [ __ ] the stack what's my phone
number we write it down and shut the
camera oh my god
what's my address yeah right what's my
social security number
you guys really my friends how come he
is oh
all right do you guys think i am a
do-it-yourself kind of person or a pay
for someone else to do it oh come on
that's too easy
is it huh
[ __ ]
because if it was tiff
i know that answer but also um [ __ ] hmm
sure why not all right ready
one wait okay
two
three pay pay all the way
i think it's a little bit wait you
didn't write yours i know because i i
don't have to write it down but i think
it's a little bit of a trick question
because like i actually do a lot of
stuff myself like your house and
everything you decorate yourself yeah
like i clean everything myself yeah pay
for cleaners like i do like the the only
thing that i feel like i pay all the
time for definitely is like
i pay
for delivery for food because like i
don't like cooking yeah about valley
parking sometimes i'll pay for valet i
will pay for value every goddamn time
how about for well the fact that you get
those fancy apartments with all the
amenities tells me like you're more of
like a
my
like i want to pay for luxuries and time
is luxury yeah and effort is luxury
yeah whatever you know what i mean
yeah i in some ways there's probably
some things that i'm paying for for sure
but i still feel like i do a lot so i
don't know that one's kind of hard for
me to gauge anyway but i just wanted to
know what you guys
initial reaction was
yeah i still do a lot like i yeah i do a
lot of cleaning and putting things
together and decorating and like
for example if you needed like you own
your home
would you be fixing your house or paying
for someone to come and fix it i would
probably pay someone that's exactly what
i'm talking about yeah exactly
fix things because i just don't have the
that's a do-it-yourself thing yeah i
don't really have the skill for it and
i'd rather be done correctly exactly so
you're a pay girl like if you saw a
piece of furniture
that you really wanted would you rather
pay for it full price or buy
uh like a do-it-yourself version you can
just do it yourself yeah i would just
buy it i knew it yeah yeah we get this
we get the point so we get yeah we get
the point so i guess like in my head i
was counting too much of like uh i will
clean and like do a lot of things myself
too but yeah for the bigger
things in life yeah i probably pay for
it yeah
okay last one
is um
what's my safe word
oh interesting you've never talked about
this that i can remember i'm just i just
want to see what you guys come up with
hmm that'd be hilarious if one of us
guessed it
i feel like we've never heard it because
we've never been in that situation you
know right
have we ever talked about safe words i
don't think we have i don't know if
you've ever told it to us it seems like
something i know you like to get your
ass beat and when you're having sex
i don't know what your word is what is
it is it a single word or a phrase a
single word okay you wrote something
yeah oh [ __ ] um i don't know why but i'm
thinking of this i don't think this is
it i think i i feel like mine's from a
million
whole movie i'm not sure i can't wait to
see this all right ready one two three
pineapple
[ __ ]
what is that
where is that frog
where's pineapple from no
but also like i'm disappointed do you
guys really think that i would have such
a basic
that's a safe word kept coming today
commenters please let us know we're
looking for where's pineapple from
that's like the most basic one my safe
word
is
autopsy
yes see it works like a charm
yeah it's a very effective i don't know
the safest word like the moment i say
also shared that with us oh really i've
shared it on my stream and stuff yeah i
know she hasn't i don't think she's all
that i don't remember this why the [ __ ]
did we remember i am disappointed that
you guys would think that would have
such a basic common safe word
i felt like we had a conversation yeah
something about pineapple autopsy but i
could just be remembering a movie i
don't
know
hard to say yeah like that's not like in
my like if you're having sex i feel like
you'd be like oh pineapple both three
syllable words but like
autopsy oh my god
okay
oh my
god autopsy
okay
it works
bigger question
how many times have you yes this safe
once once yeah just one time
so you've discussed this with every guy
that you've been with how long has it
been your safe word
or do you have a different safe word for
each card oh
good question we i can dig let's see
the general word is autopsy like that's
my general you know i've never had to
use it with anyone but then i feel like
every relationship like [ __ ] you have
sex with
but every relationship i go into i think
we come up with like a new safe word you
know what is that how do you want to
measure it
we just do not like you're just a person
if you never have to use it yeah i don't
think i've had one for every
relationship you know i think i've had
one for one and i don't remember which
one
like what the word was you have one now
uh are you willing to share that no
don't have one now okay because he's not
an [ __ ]
who wouldn't know when to stop yeah yeah
true
all right topsy autopsy autopsy
we're ending this this uh video right
now so autopsies
i'm gonna autopsy my way out of this
video
uh thanks for watching guys hope you
guys enjoyed this game uh it was really
fun seeing each other's answers but um
uh make sure you guys check out our
sponsors give us a like and follow we'll
see you guys next week and we love you
be good again it's me gina tiff and jess
yeah see you later bye
[Music]
you